Jacob was home over
quarantine and uh I'll tell you you
we're empty nesters and one of the best
things about being an empty nester is
you can just go back to having sex
whenever or wherever you want you know
and um so one night Beth and I were
upstairs Jacob was in the house and I
say to her we're in our room and I go
hey she goes yeah I go hey you want
to you want to roll
around and she goes
Jacob's in the house and I was like
We'll turn up the
[Applause]
TV she goes he's not
[Music]
eight and I was like yeah but let's just
give it a try you
know so I come downstairs the next
morning and Jacob is at the dining room
table
he's eating cereal like
[Applause]
this I go what how's it going buddy he
goes not
great I said what's going on he goes do
you have to have sex in the
house
I was like well where do
you where do you want me to have sex and
he goes anywhere but in the house new
rule new
rule no having sex while I'm in the
house new rule no having sex while I'm
in the
house and I go dude you don't get to
make
rules this is my house I'll wipe my dick
on the butter if I want to do you
understand
I might have sex tomorrow in your room
otherwise known as my other room
dude new rule [__]
[Applause]
you I will tell you though it's finally
happened to me guys you know as a I can
always speak as a guy and as a guy you
never think sex is ever going to be Dro
on your priority list you look at older
guys and you're like whatever I'm going
to [__] time
80 and as you get older it just drops on
the priority this listen man you're 23
right okay so this is your girlfriend
I'm not saying you specifically but a
23y old man this is the difference that
I know between the two of
us if a 23y old dude was dead asleep at
2: a.m.
there are guys in here already laughing
they know
exactly dead asleep 2:
a.m. and a girl text you and she lives 4
hours
away she's like if you get in your car
right now and make it here by 6:00 a.m.
I'm going to show you half a titty he'd
be like bye
it's just the age not you in particular
but just the age right here's the
difference here's the difference oh
here's the
difference first of all I'm going to say
something that a lot of people in here
will understand how amazing it is last
week my wife and I wanted to have sex on
the same
[Applause]
night nobody's birth
birthday was it Christmas like it's just
a
Wednesday this is how old I am do you
want to know why we didn't have sex down
that
night she was
upstairs I was
downstairs she said come up and I said
come
down we didn't talk for the rest of the
night that was
it I was like I'm not walking up a
flight of stairs at 10 p.m. [__]
[Applause]
you I was also I was like I'm I'm going
to wait that vagina out it's going to be
hungry for breakfast tomorrow it's
coming it's coming downstairs I know I
know it's coming
downstairs